ينضم الينا من الاسماعيليه سكرتير عامل
الاتحاد المصري للمصارع للمصارعه الدكتور
محمود السيد دكتور محمود اهلا بك يعني
بودنا ان نتساءل ما هي القصه من وجهه
نظركم
كاتحاد مصري للمصارعه ما الذي حدث
اهلا
من الفئه الثانيه لانه ما كانش لحد وقتنا
هذا حصل على ميداليه ذهبيه للكبار في
افريقيا والفئه الاولى بالنسبه لنا هم
ابطال افريقيا للكبار
لما احنا كنا طبعا مديينه وعد انه بعد
البطوله دي ان شاء الله كل اللي هيجيب اول
افريقيا هيتحط في الفئه الاولى طبعا الولد
كان في حاجه اسمها رسوم انتقال هو كان
منتقل من من الهيئه الهيئه تانيه دي لها
رسوم انتقال الرسوم كانت مقدره بحوالي
12,000 جنيه بالنسبه لبغدوده طبعا احنا
كسبت ليه احنا مش يعني مش هنخليك تدفع
المبلغ ده احنا هنديك المستحقات ماليه ومن
اول مستحقات ماليه نبقى نخصمها منك يبقى
انت كده ما دفعتش المفروض ان الفلوس دي
بتدفع قبل انتقاله بس احنا الولد حولنا
نعمل معاه اكسبت كويس شويه ان احنا نعمله
ده عشان ما يدفعش من جيبه طبعا الولد لما
جه اول مستحقات ماليه كان اول ست شهور له
ب 18,000 جنيه طبعا خصم منه الضرائب
العاديه خالص اللي بتقسمها الدوله اللي هي
ال 10% كسب عمل و3% ضريبه وده حاجه زي كده
يعني قوانين رولز معينه اتخصم منه بقى
النسبه بتاعه الانتقالات بتاعته اللي هو
كان المفروض يسددها واحنا ما دخلناش
يسددها في بدايه الانتقالات يعني عملنا له
تاجيل لها شويه هو ده المفروض انه كان
هيرجع كان هيرجع من بطوله افريقيا ديت
اتحرقت الفئه الاولى بتاعنا وكان ياخذ له
ست شهور كمان هياخدهم كاملين بدون اي
استقطاعات او خصومات طيب دلوقتي
حضرتك بتقول احنا وعدنا وقلنا له بس ترجع
وبالتالي
الرجل لم يرجع بل ذهب الى الى فرنسا الان
ما الذي سيعيد الى مصر مره اخرى
والله يعني اللي هيعيده طبعا مسرح مصر
فيها ابطال كتير قوي في مصر فيها لعيبه
كتير قوي ولاده والولد من الناس المؤدبه
والمحبه اللي احنا كنا بنرعاها بنحترمها
طبعا بعد جهاز السيد مع رئيس الجمهوريه
برعايته ورعايه كل ابطال اللي زيه يعني هو
مبارح معي الرئيس مش وجه برعايه بغدوده بس
كمان ده قال لك زي بغدوده ومحتاج رعايه ده
هيتعارف هيتراع اتفضل دكتور مهو ربما هذه
هي المشكله بانه لماذا يجب الامور ان تصل
الى حد انه يهرب يهرب احد الرياضيين اللي
انتم متوقعين اله مستقبل وهو على كفاءه
عاليه حتى يتم الاعتناء بالرياضيين في مصر
هل هناك تقصير في دعم هؤلاء الرياضيين
ماديا وبالتدريب رغم انه هناك مواهب كبيره
نتحدث عن 120 مليون
مصري اكيد في مواهب بالملايين
والله هقول لحضرتك على حاجه احنا في
الفتره ديت وكان من ازهر فترات اللي
بتعيشها العاب الفرديه بنلاقي دعم مادي
ومعنوي كبير قوي من اجهزه الدوله من وزاره
الشباب والرياضه الاولمبيه المصريه مش
عايز اقول لحضرتك احنا بدانا ناخد مكانش
في حاجه اسمها مرتبات للعيبه كانوا
بياخدوا مصروف جيب في المعسكرات الداخليه
عاديه النهارده بدانا نحط ليفل للمرتبات
وكان الليفل ده قابل للزياده احنا بدانا
بدانا الخطوه بشكل كويس قوي وبدا يبقى في
رعايه كويسه قوي كل ابطال البغدوده احنا
عندنا ابطال كتير قوي عندنا كيش وعندنا
عبد اللطيف اتفضل يا دكتور دلوقتي الدول
الاخرى والدول الاوروبيه التي تبحث حتى عن
محترفين للتميز ومشاركه هؤلاء المواهب
تعطيهم ما يفوق ايضا ربما الامكانات التي
موجوده في الدول العربيه لا اتحدث فقط عن
مصر اتحدث عن كل الدول الافريقيه
والاسيويه وكذلك العربيه
المغريات كبيره جدا يا دكتور محمود وانت
تعلم ذلك
طيب شكرا اكيد طبعا بس كل واحد بيبرر
هروبه من وجهه نظره هو لا هو ايضا ربما
ايضا طيب هذا الموضوع ربما متشعب في
الايام القادمه دكتور محمود السيد مدير
عام او سكرتير عام الاتحاد المصري
للمصارعه شكرا جزيلا لك
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات